yeah let's jump into this first story
man this crazy stuff we got this from
timcast.com breaking shelter in place
issued in Tucson Arizona following
hazardous material leak on I-10
civilians within a one mile radius have
been ordered to evacuate the stretch of
road has reportedly been closed in both
directions at milepost 272 civilians
within a one mile radius in order to
evacuate the Arizona Department of
Transportation has not issued an
estimated time for i-10's reopening as
of this report uh reports publication we
have this video from
alerts is that you say it let's see if
we can uh we can play this take a look
at this let me get the uh audio going
for you guys there we go
oh my God so I don't know what that
yellow stuff spraying out of there is
but I certainly wouldn't want to be
anywhere near it
so there it is I mean simply put they
say Tucson's National Weather Service
cautioned drivers of dense blowing dust
prior to the trucks overturning
motorists traveling along I-10 should be
prepared for rapidly reduced visibility
below a mile to blowing dust